bah-bah-bah royalty-free sumo killing
time in any way for the sake of this
meeting I can put aside your disloyalty
and sworn allegiance to the destruction
of the first order what I cannot sweep
under the rug however these are
microaggressions and lack of diversity
in your safe space yeah I know I know
Who am I to lecture you after all you
are a woman and you are a tattoo
American black like just just come on
okay not that's cool I just didn't want
to assume the plug remains there are all
different kinds of levers me across the
scram galaxy ours and then I fairly
represented by the Tusken Raiders and
how dare you make such assumptions with
passion prejudice right confirm yes they
were Tuscan Raider that's a big surprise
who do you think you are
you know nothing on the intricacies of
their ancient yet beautiful and
mysterious culture now we have
spaceships and joys and they're still
fighting over one patch of land with
harpoons I think I got what do you talk
like that you're no better than the dark
side or the Tusken Raiders themselves we
still don't target innocent desert
crossers or make our women dress up like
ninjas so disagree pretend like I didn't
hear that on to item number two ray we
found this in your ward this outfit has
been banned from future merchandising
because it was designed to be
titillating and or sexually rambunctious
and it encourages patriarchy so I said
okay when Elena wears this hey you guys
look at me I'm like super brave to wear
this I hope nobody tries enrage me get
off my space was a little much you
completely violated her safe force field
and it's a capacity on that blaster
below the reasons fairly not something
it's a laser blaster it's unlimited
then why the bear with a crossbow Lucas
can't write first yeah I heard that we
even had to bring back Mark Hamill yeah
the snack there have some self-respect
for God's sakes look in a mirror no it's
not true
it's impossible did you keep a food log
head
cripes I can see your thyroid from here
why are there no transgender Whoopi
they're asexual so okay would you mind
if we called you pad section
thank you for your ATAR ones i am number
three i would like to present to you the
new all-inclusive super tolerant LGBTQ a
ifc WX - the costume
you gotta be kidding even I couldn't
pick them from a rooftop full of okay
everyone let's not assume anything
video subscribe by clicking my face
if you don't probably murder your mother